so in one word you what is your
professional style that's one word
visionary so i'm here with hugh evans
the co-founder of the global poverty
project those can just explain for
viewers what that is yeah sure the
global poverty project is an
international education and advocacy
organization committed to a world
without extreme poverty within a
generation so we focus within a
generation correct yeah within generate
25 years and so we focus our efforts on
building the movement to end extreme
poverty and running large-scale
campaigns that can influence government
and business policy relating to issues
that affect the world's poor and you
just had a really amazing event here in
New York City in September you had a
concert in Central Park and tell us a
little bit about who performed and how
that all worked sure so the idea of the
global citizen festival is we didn't
want to just run another benefit concert
we want to turn the idea on its head so
we game of five the whole experience by
making sure so for those who don't know
the word game if I which might be many
people can you explain what that means
it means that um basically participants
had to earn their way into the concert
through taking actions in support of the
world's poor online so that to tweet
about it share it on Facebook that to
watch videos educate themselves and
through all these actions they earn
points and they redeem their points for
tickets to the concert and so it was
really amazing because we had over 600
96,000 actions taken in the month before
the festival online in support of people
so when every one came to the concert it
wasn't like a regular benefit concert
where you work out on the day what it's
all about everyone was already
passionate about the cause they were all
there for the right reasons which is
really powerful and so we had Neil Young
we had with Crazy Horse we had the Foo
Fighters the Black Keys k naan we had
band of horses and we even had John let
John Legend make a surprise appearance
and sing imagine and it was incredible
it was broadcast all around the world
over 15 million viewers and reached over
two billion people through the press so
it was quite incredible so let me be a
little bit of a cynic I mean I'm not
sure that that taking act that tweeting
about something or watching a video or
LAN or post on Facebook is really taking
action I know a lot of people that are
under 30 an hour three might consider
that real
but is that really a house that really
helped well the important thing is
global citizen we've been making the
actions more and more sophisticated as
we go along so for example volunteering
is something that we're now being able
to measure through an online tool which
previously weren't donating is another
example which we can now measure call in
a politician or visiting a politician in
Congress is something we can now measure
so if we're committed to making our
actions more and more sophisticated but
it's important because obviously Central
Park is governed by the state of New
York in the city of New York you're not
allowed to kind of force people to take
really high benchmark actions in the
first year but because it was so
successful everyone now sees it as a
precedent for how it cannot move forward
so we've been making the actions more
and more sophisticated and therefore
more and more impactful for the world's
poor I think I saw some number that you
do you got 1.3 billion dollars in
commitments out of that so explain to me
what that means that people committed
and actually given the money right
correct it but they've made commitments
and who did where does that money go who
regulates that sure so we had a number
of charity partners that were accredited
charity partners for the global citizen
festival one of them for example was the
global partnership for education and the
World Bank together with the global
partnership for education got on stage
and they've committed to raising five
hundred million dollars in new funding
for education in fragile states and over
the coming two years there now committed
to delivering it we adopted a similar
model to say clinton global where people
come on stage make commitments and are
willing to be held accountable for the
delivery of those commitments another
example was for example half the sky
which is coalition put together by
nicholas kristof the journalists and
others they got 160 million dollars in
new commitments towards the empowerment
of women so they got a coalition of some
of the world's best charities like
Somali mum opportunity international
microfinance everyone working together
that came together to form this
commitment another example was there was
a 500 million dollar commitment towards
funding for core programs for the US
fund for unicef and so that's a
commitment the last over the next three
years and we'll be checking in with
unicef and with all of our partners
every six months to ensure they're on
track towards achieving those targets
that's really impressive it really
and what how do you define extreme
poverty not you know I hear all these
things people living on a dollar a day
living a two dollar a day been you know
I don't know how meaningful those
numbers really always are but there are
sort of a you have you have a definition
I'm sure sure I mean extreme poverty is
defined by the World Bank on those
living on less than us one dollar 25 per
day and but it's really any people is
that roughly will blow it's between 1.1
and 1.4 billion people on this planet
who live in extreme poverty there
readjusting the X percent of the world's
by British correct yeah but the good
news is that in the last 25 years the
proportion of people living in extreme
poverty is actually haft from fifty two
percent of the world's population in
nineteen eighty one donor twenty-five
percent in 2005 so enormous progress has
been made but when we talk about it's
not just about the amount of money you
actually have it's about access to
education healthcare food water and
sanitation Rio the empowerment of women
these are the sorts of indicators that
we use to measure whether someone is or
is not an extreme poverty here we only
have a minute left but I want to ask you
one last sort of question so for
somebody's watching this that wants to
actually make a difference to the world
what would you suggest well what can
people do I think people are often see
these problems and they're so big and
the numbers are so overwhelming they
just feel like ah I think there's two
things you can do firstly I'd encourage
everyone to go to global citizen org and
identify what charity or issue you're
particularly passionate about so what
we've designed is we've outlined a
plethora of issues whether it's polio
malaria water food education and people
we know that everyone comes from a
different perspective we want everyone
to be able to use this as their gateway
for action the second thing I'd say is
that your voice is as powerful as your
wallet so don't just make a donation
actually use the website to actually
call your member of Congress and
encourage them to take action because we
veer towards a fiscal cliff at the
moment we need to actually ensure that
Congress doesn't cut aid to the world's
poorest and this is not just the case
for America it's the same in Britain the
same in Canada the same in Australia and
all across the OECD nations we need to
ensure that governments uphold the
commitments they've made in line with
the United Nations Millennium
Development Goal target of 0 point seven
of gross national income given to the
world's poor